when I saw in the spider-verse I didn't  even know I knew nothing about it I  didn't know that you were in the film  you were a voice and when your character  came on it was a really nice surprise it  was and you were fantastic oh thank you  it was such an amazing touch an amazing  thing to be part of and when they said  you need to play like a fast-talking pig  who's a news reporter from the 40s I  said I got this the oscar-winning  spider-man into the spider verse is  available this is important ladies and  gentlemen and it's featuring an  exclusive mini movie with spider him he  got your own mini movies I did it I did  a small feature at to continue the story  of spider hand that I was very excited  about and you can see it on the blu-ray  John Mulaney  abs when I is just absolutely thrilled  absolutely thrilled to have you on the  show you really are my hero and you're  the greatest and I thank you for having  me on  [Applause]